how do you discern truth from fiction
this is from Tom La Jones one of the
things I found hardest in the last few
weeks or months is how much false
information there's been thrown around I
personally have felt like I've lost
friends and teachers because they become
so engrossed in 5-g anti-vaccine cetera
conspiracy theories that it's tainted
all the lessons I've received from them
in the past which I also pass on as a
yoga teacher myself my question to you
or invitation for a topic of
conversation is how to discern truth
from non truth how to know who to listen
to and trust and why it even matters
perhaps if I simply turn the news off
and turned off my conspiracy theory
pushing friends on social media or just
turn that off altogether life would be
simpler this is a tough one life would
be simpler of course but I don't know
that it would be better and to the
extent that that Tom is questioning
whether or not truth matters let me be
very clear truth matters truth matters
more now than ever if we can't agree
upon what is true and what isn't true
how do we move forward as a society and
I think we're in a very precarious
moment right now where truth is being
questioned all over the place and the
firm ground upon which we stand in terms
of what is real and what isn't
is becoming more and more difficult to
discern and it's deeply concerning to me
truth is incredibly important and I
don't know how we got to this place
where we have become so distrustful of
vetted sources and so prone to believing
things from dubious sources that it's
made conversation back to this issue of
conversation very difficult mm-hmm right
I don't know what else to say other than
that is incumbent upon Tom myself you
all of us to vet the sources of our
information to be more mindful and
conscientious about
our information silos and where we are
receiving information from we can be
open-minded
to go back to the other question but we
can't be we can't allow ourselves to be
susceptible to the level of manipulation
that we're seeing right now and I think
that vetting your sources is important
now that doesn't mean that perhaps the
New York Times doesn't bend in a certain
direction politically but there is
something to be said for the
journalistic ethic and the standards of
journalism that are required to produce
stories for legitimate news outlet and
outlets you know you can receive those
from different points along the
political spectrum but I think when
you're reading blog posts and you don't
know who wrote this or where this
information came from or you're just
digesting clickbait headlines it's
problematic so I don't know what else to
say other than that you really need to
vet your resource your sources you know
completely whether it's podcasts
newspapers television programs news
programs whatever mm-hmm and and what
about the when you see people you
respect start to trade in these
conspiracy theories or unproven theories
forget conspiracy but just unproven
theories where does your mind go yeah I
mean first of all not all conspiracy
theories are untrue right many of them
are so I don't want it we're not going
to debate you know which one of these
are true or not right now but there are
conspiracies willing to say five g's and
you're true there are there there are
there are some conspiracies that you
know it's like that that they have
validity so I think when you're engaging
with somebody like that you could just
say tell me more about that you know
allow them to you know but you have to
be convicted
in your own sense of reality I think to
do that you know but you know you you
don't have to engage those people no you
don't you don't have to get into an
argument with them you don't have to
follow them on social media it's not
your obligation to prove them wrong no
you have a choice about what you consume
so if this has become problematic for
you turn off the television and get off
social media and go outdoors and enjoy
your life and your family and your
children
life is short man no I think I think
what he's saying though the one thing
that is problematic with you know for a
long time this has been building this
direction there's a flattening of the
media landscape where it used to think
you used to be able to tell really
quickly what's a legitimate news source
and what isn't just by looking at it
feeling the newspaper or the magazine in
your hands in a longer hour and now it's
harder to see
so there's flattening of that landscape
now for someone who works as a
journalist I always will trust the
journalist on the ground before I'll
trust almost anybody just because
they're there and just like I would
trust a doctor who's been through
medical school or through you know when
it's an acute situation then I will some
guy right um but there has been this
desire and it's not just in in
journalism but there has been this
movement to attack the expert you're
right that's new that's new and what you
do is you love to bring in experts and
probe experts and try to figure out
what's going on so for the betterment of
your listenership it's interesting that
now the expert whether it's a CDC guy or
whether you know whoever it is you know
whether it's found out if you're in or
you're the first person to be dismissed
why should I trust you you know an
expert right you're an expert why should
I trust you it's very strange a very
bizarre where everything is a little
upside-down right now but I think the
reason it's not you know that it matters
is because now basically in a real way
our lives depend on it
you know like we can't have some people
not we can and we are some people are
choosing not to believe in it but the
virus numbers will go up so then I think
one answer to tom is just like you have
to stay awake yourself and realize that
and make choices knowing that you have
to put yourself in charge yeah I think
and take responsibility for your
information diet in a way that we didn't
happen we didn't used to have to know
right no but it is strange that now the
first people we call into question are
the expert yeah like how did we get to
that point and again it goes back to a
breakdown in our ability to basically be
on the same page about anything yeah and
I think you know part of the process of
evaluating your source material is is
objectively trying to understand like
the the the motivations behind the piece
right like who stands to benefit from
this what is this person's point of view
why are they advocating for this in this
way like if you can read with a critical
eye I think that puts you already you
know way ahead of the game yeah but now
everybody's so so because news
narratives seem to shift so frequently
it's led to this level of distrust and I
think it creates a Ana mean ability to
conspiracy theories in order for the
human brain to try to make sense of the
of a kit of a world that that feels like
it's in chaos because if there's a grand
unifying theory to everything then you
can sleep at night thinking this makes
sense right there's there's so many that
you could go to I mean I for me with
conspiracy theories I always think of as
it all comes ray razors yeah yeah like
the simplest explanation is usually the
one that's true so which kind of usually
eviscerates most conspiracy theories but
that demands somebody's playing like
eight dimensional chess right like like
like it's usually not that it's usually
most things come down to human and
confidence right
I tell you that right beretta for that
callback as Greta she will tell you most
things come down to human incompetence
it's not evil its incompetence
well you've written for the New York
Times and all kinds of you know how dare
you yeah time right yeah how dare you
know talk a little bit about that
journalistic ethic and and what goes
into that well I mean there's a level of
fact-checking and in major publications
where you know you're gonna you're gonna
have an editor or research editor go
back through and contact your sources to
make sure these things happened or you
prove it with taped interviews or
whatever where it becomes clear so
there's a level of fact-checking that go
on with professional publications that
don't go on for most web only articles
so almost almost no but that's not
necessarily always true I also write for
long reads which is web only and they do
the best pub best fact-checking I've
ever had done but there was a time when
web only meant no fact-checking right
and print meant fact-checking
I will always trust a journalist on the
ground that doesn't mean journalists
don't get things wrong I think someone
wrote I forget who it was I wish I had
this in my fingertips or I could or it
would be good entertaining to watch me
google it but you know someone wrote
journalism is the first draft at history
so and Gladwell often says Malcolm
Gladwell often says um the later you are
the smarter you have to be which is
basically acknowledging that the first
draft of history isn't always the most
accurate but it is a version man it is
the most accurate version at that time
that's what you're hoping to do as a
reporter when I go into something I've
done many many times most of the stuff
I've done has been reported before just
not by me so then the you're not
breaking news no I have I've had the
opportunity to do that too and it's it's
liberating because you know you don't
have to you just have to be smarter than
nothing but you still want to do a great
job right because you want to be you
want to make it harder for anyone to
follow you to find stuff you didn't find
but so I've done both but most of the
time I do the latter so so in that case
you know ahead what's
been done and you know where the holes
are and that your that's your role to
fill it but when you're doing it when
you're when you're covering protests on
the ground or whatever or a Trump rally
or something happening in the moment
there are deadlines that happen you have
to turn in your copy right away there's
someone working on it immediately for
the New York Times specifically you turn
something in it's getting turned
especially if it's a breaking story
it's getting turned around right away
within hours and it's up on the website
before it's even in the paper and it can
be six hours or three hours after you've
turned it in and the pressure to be
first to print yeah is huge right yes
inevitably is gonna lead to errors and
reporting yeah and the whole the whole
system is premise taun an ad model right
it's driven by clicks so it's inherently
problematic for that reason but it's
nice to see some of these platforms
moving to subscription model I really
think that's the future right how do we
gonna get independent you know
well-reasoned considered journalism when
it's about what is the title you know
how are we gonna get this many people to
click on this title and see these banner
ads you know it's important to say just
because journalists make mistakes
sometimes they do art often the best
place to interpret something because
they're there they're usually studying
it often especially with the New York
Times they're experts in a particular
area or they've been working on a
specific desk for a period of time so
they they have the most sources really
they're the ones talking to the most
people about that very specific thing
and we have this problem now where we
don't have faith which we choose not to
have faith unless we've seen it
ourselves it's like it's like a reversal
of some kind like it's almost like the
natural like blowback from what it used
to be like when I was growing up we
wanted to be iconic laughs we wanted to
be we wanted to go against the grain
I read the LA Weekly specifically
because it was a different point of view
turn to the alternative point of view
but now everyone's looking for that
alternative and and and so it's no
longer just the people on the edge of
culture looking for that now it's
everybody in culture looking for that
it's beyond just silo ization although
that's part of
what we're talking about it's it's this
it's this doubt that is so did about
almost everything right like we doubt
our doctors we doubt the CDC guy we
doubt our journalists we doubt we doubt
too much I used to be into being a rebel
but now we doubt too much we're afraid
to trust there's a trust deficit and and
it's incredibly destabilizing yep across
the board for all of us when we're all
doubting on that level and we can't
agreed upon some kind of shared ground
yeah I had David Katz on the podcast a
while back he wrote an op-ed for the New
York Times at the very beginning of the
pandemic about his perspective on kovat
and whether you agree with his
perspective or not is irrelevant what
happened was it took he told me it took
10 days of back-and-forth with the
editors fact-checking changing this to
make sure that everything was like fully
vetted and by the end of that 10 10-day
period all the stats had changed again
because this thing was written they had
to change it again and like the
elaborate you know amount of effort that
went into just that simple op-ed that
looks like you just write it and it goes
up was way more than I think people
realize like way more than meets the eye
and it's stuff like that that gives me
you know that gives me confidence that
when I pick up a legitimate publication
like that that I'm getting something
different than I'm that I'm gonna get
from a blogger with an agenda yet with
no editorial oversight yeah there you go
[Music]